con nuestro primer invitado al día vamos
a hablar de las declaraciones del
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin que
endureció su discurso a medida que
avanza la guerra Putin aseguró que el
mundo se encuentra en un punto de
inflexión histórico y advirtió que el
planeta al planeta la espera el decenio
más peligroso también impredecible desde
los tiempos de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
vamos a hablar con Antonio barrios
Oviedo analista especialista en
conflictos internacionales y en origen y
ampliación de la otan gracias Antonio
por estar con nosotros esta mañana de
miércoles en directo América de Francia
24 porque entonces el presidente rusola
demir Putin a medida que avanzan los
días de guerra los días de Invasión a
Ucrania aumenta no con más agresividad
digamos su discurso bélico sobre todo a
los países de Occidente
Buenos días Don Raúl un saludo desde
Costa Rica Y gracias por la invitación
sí sin duda el presidente Putin está en
una situación complicada es decir ha
perdido algunos territorios El Avance o
la ofensiva del ejército ucraniano y
como ya todos bien sabemos si no hubiera
sido por la ayuda occidental pues
prácticamente el gobierno ucraniano hace
tiempo ya hubiera caído estos avances
que el ejército ucraniano Ha logrado
tener el arrebatarle algunos territorios
que han sido importantes para el punto
de vista estratégico para Putin eso ha
hecho que definitivamente el presidente
Putin de alguna manera se sienta
acorralado hay una crisis a nivel de
fuerzas armadas recordemos también que
este toda esta retórica o toda esta
teatralidad de lo que significa anunciar
la posibilidad de lanzar algún tipo de
armamento táctico que sobrepasa las
características de cualquier guerra
convencional como la que se está
viviendo en Ucrania pues pone
definitivamente en un serio peligro el
curso de esta guerra más de lo que
quizás no se hubiera como se ha visto
digamos en otros conflictos Entonces el
sentirse acorralado lleva de alguna
manera amenazar a otro nivel distinto
del que ya no pueda dentro del esquema
de guerra convencional Y eso de alguna
manera lo lleva a tener que actuar de
esa manera no se justifica de alguna
manera llegar hasta ese extremo Porque
todavía Yo soy de los que creo que la
diplomacia puede todavía hacer mucho
para terminar con esta guerra o por lo
menos la mediación de terceros países
pero Sí definitivamente esto es un serio
peligro para el curso de la guerra en
Ucrania y lo que puede significar para
Europa y el resto del mundo Antonio
Incluso el presidente habla de mi Putin
a pesar de esta escalada de su discurso
no más directo contra occidente y
también pues lanzar estas amenazas
nucleares de alguna manera
Hay realmente las posibilidades de que
se sienten en la mesa las partes porque
a lo que iba Putin a escalado su
discurso pero también ha dicho que hay
que sentarse a negociar no que sería
como la la única manera después arreglar
todo este conflicto pero negociar en qué
condiciones en qué términos porque
evidentemente Putin va a querer negociar
a su manera y lo que le convenga y
ucranes también entonces cómo encontrar
este punto intermedio bueno el punto
intermedio tendrá que ver en que cuando
uno habla de negociación las partes que
van a negociar tienen que ceder en algo
es decir no solamente una parte tiene
que aceptar los términos de la otra sino
que negociación Precisamente es tratar
de buscar ese punto intermedio que hasta
el momento ha sido difícil recordemos
que Francia en algún momento trató de
mediar para la terminación de conflictos
por lo menos que no continuara hace
algunos meses Turquía también ha estado
en medio china le ha pedido a Rusia de
que ya ve por finalizado este conflicto
la misma India que de alguna manera no
se ha atrevido a condenar esta guerra en
Ucrania ha buscado también la manera y
ya en otras oportunidades se lo dijo en
la conferencia de Shanghai hace pocos
meses le dijo al presidente Putin de que
buscara opciones de negociación para ver
cómo termina pero Sí definitivamente yo
creo que más allá de cualquier mediación
de terceros países aquí Lo importante es
que tanto Ucrania como Rusia están
dispuestos a ceder algo a cambio de
crear un ambiente de negociación y
mientras que eso no exista cualquier
esfuerzo de país de terceros países para
ser posible una negociación pues
prácticamente seguiría estando nula Y
entonces el curso de la guerra Va a
continuar como tal y todas estas
amenazas de Putin pues que lo llevan a
tratar de buscar algún punto de quiebre
que haga que el régimen de kiev busque
de alguna manera de alguna salida ante
este tipo de amenazas de armas tácticas
de las cuales el régimen de kiev
difícilmente podría enfrentarse Bueno
hablemos de algo que sucedió hoy fue que
el presidente Turco reyerta y perduana
dijo que en efecto Rusia ya regresó a el
marco y a respetar las reglas del juego
en el acuerdo de exportación de granos
desde Ucrania recordemos que Rusia se
salió eh unilateralmente el día sábado
por un ataque en sebasto porque pues de
hecho la culpa a los ucranianos de este
ataque esto sería una muestra de
Vladimir Putin de de ceder en algunas
cosas estaría también un poco debilitado
el kremlin no ante esta guerra y ante
toda la presión occidental Bueno siempre
siempre se considera Don Raúl que
aún en tiempos de guerra cualquier acto
de buena voluntad de alguna de las
partes sin conflicto para ceder por lo
menos en materia alimentaria y no
afectar al resto de la población o a
nivel regional lo que significa la
exportación de los granos Yo creo que es
una buena muestra de lo que este en este
caso digamos Putin ha buscado ha buscado
hacer yo creo que la guerra no debe
exceder Más allá de cualquier límite de
lo que significa poner en peligro al
resto de al resto de la humanidad o a
nivel incluso a nivel regional y yo creo
que esto es una buena muestra pues Putin
está demostrando para ver si
gradualmente puede ir este creándose
otras condiciones con la ayuda de
Turquía que ha sido uno de los
fuertemente han estado detrás de esta
dinámica tratar de ver cómo se logra de
alguna manera algún tipo de acercamiento
evidentemente tanto selensky como Putin
ha reiterado en muchas oportunidades que
ellos no están dispuestos a ceder y que
incluso el mismo salen es que con
justificar razón ha dicho de que no hay
opción de negociación mientras que Rusia
no se retire de Ucrania Pues eso
Igualmente como lo dije antes va a
imposibilitar que algún ambiente de
negociación salga adelante hablemos de
estas amenazas nucleares que han estado
sobre la mesa la última fue con esta
posibilidad de lanzamiento de una
posible bomba sucia que Rusia dijo que
Ucrania estaría dispuesta a usar en su
territorio Ucrania dijo que no que era
Rusia que quería usar este tipo de armas
también con el apoyo de occidente no a
Ucrania con todo este tema de la bomba
sucia no que evidentemente tiene
elementos radioactivos
cómo está el terreno nuclear en este
punto de la guerra también se lo
pregunto porque esto genera
evidentemente un ambiente de ansiedad de
de un poco de miedo a nivel a nivel
global no Bueno las dos potencias
globales en este caso
Rusia y Estados Unidos son los que
siguen estando a la vanguardia Por
decirlo así en la tenencia armamento
nuclear es decir misiles balísticos
intercontinentales que tanto los tiene
Rusia como Estados Unidos
paradójicamente china a pesar de ser una
potencia también militar es el que tiene
menos ojivas nucleares tiene
aproximadamente 150 en comparación a las
casi 2500 que tiene Rusia y a las 3000 y
algo que incluso Rusia tiene Entonces en
ese sentido cuando uno ve
la preocupación que a nivel global puede
haber este sea una bomba de uranio o de
una bomba sucia o lo que lo que Rusia
digamos allá pretendido en sus amenazas
al lanzar contra Ucrania pues
definitivamente una bomba que que vaya a
lanzar Rusia no va a cambiar el curso de
la guerra en Ucrania porque no una bomba
táctica tiene un alcance en realidad muy
corto y un nivel de destrucción bastante
limitado que asemejan un poco don Raúl a
las Bombas que se lanzaron en nagasaki
en Hiroshima en aquel entonces que eran
apenas de 15 kilotones mientras que las
que hoy hay con el avance de la
tecnología en materia en militar pues
prácticamente son bombas que alcanzan ya
prácticamente los 100 kilotones es decir
claro a nivel de destrucción obviamente
va a ser mayor Pero bueno hay un
ambiente de mucha incertidumbre en ese
sentido sobre la consecuencia que pueda
llegar a tener dentro de Ucrania el
lanzamiento de una sola bomba táctica
que Rusia
Determine lanzar para ver si logra
cambiar el curso de la guerra